India's top court has postponed hearings
on a new citizenship law that's provoked
protests and violence nationwide Supreme
Court judges want to get more details
about the legislation from the
government before considering petitions
the law makes it easier for non-muslims
from Afghanistan Bangladesh and Pakistan
to gain Indian citizenship critics say
that's blatant discrimination by a
government they accused of driving a
Hindu nationalist agenda four people
have been killed in demonstrations that
have spiraled out of control since the
law was introduced
despite this Prime Minister Narendra
Modi is refusing to back down
al-jazeera's soul Raman spoke
exclusively with the Supreme Court
senior advocates in New Delhi the focus
of the country's attention has been on a
university in the capital that saw a
great deal of violence on Sunday as
police fought with students and civil
society over the issue of the
citizenship Amendment Act the complaints
made by the public have now come to the
Supreme Court and joining me now is
Colin gonzalvez who's the senior
advocate to the Supreme Court thank you
for joining us on al Jazeera you were
obviously in court petitioning the
Supreme Court there were statements made
by the Chief Justice what's your overall
impression of how your case went and the
conclusion made by the Chief Justice of
India well the supreme court said that
instead of hearing it in the APICS court
straight away without going first to the
High Court may not be appropriate since
the Supreme Court would like to get the
impressions of the High Court first and
so the parties have been sent back to
the High Court and it is kept in the
High Court today at 234 hearing in terms
of the citizenship Amendment bill this
is what is the central pivotal
antagonistic piece of legislation that
is upsetting Indians across the country
what's your legal opinion about whether
this violates the the Constitution and
the essence of the Constitution well it
clearly violates article 14 of our
institution which speaks of equality
which is equality for all people
irrespective of the religion that they
profess now what's happened is the
constitutional amendment act leaves out
500,000 Muslims and allows
regularization of roughly three times
that number of Hindus and other
communities so it is discrimination on
the basis of religion non-muslims come
in you can be regularized in India as
citizens and Muslims similarly situated
you will be probably put in detention
centers and incarcerated where does the
case go down the case the constitutional
amendment act case is spending in the
Supreme Court for determination that
will happen soon and as far as our case
is concerned relating to the very brutal
assault on the students of Jamia and I
saw this personally I went to the police
stations and saw young people being
brutally beaten and I saw it in the
hospitals where they were full of
bandages and broken legs and so on our
case will be heard by the High Court at
2:30 this this afternoon calling on
solvus thanks very much for joining us
here on al Jazeera thank you very much
for your time and of course the focus of
attention here at the Supreme Court on
Wednesday as you see lots of media
behind me is four lawyers from the state
of Assam as they take their petitions to
the three-man bench of the Supreme Court
headed by the Chief Justice in the
meantime the internet has been restored
in a son and the curfew has been lifted
but the country watches this story
unfold on a daily basis